[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Hello,
everyone, and welcome to Talks
at Google.
For our first talk
of the year, I'm
delighted to introduce our
PR guru, Ellen Gunning,
with a warm welcome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLEN GUNNING: Good
morning, how are you?
My book, as you
can see behind me,
is called "10 Red Hot Tips
to Promotoe Your Business."
Basically, it's geared to people
in the small-to-medium-size
enterprises.
And it's really teaching them
how to promote their business
by using PR tools.
So all of the tools
in it are PR tools.
I thought I might
begin by trying
to get us to agree on
what PR actually is.
An awful lot of people think
PR is free advertising.
YOu're in Google.
You know advertising
isn't free, right?
[LAUGHTER]
Advertising, you buy the
space, you put something in it.
And the purpose of advertising
is to sell a product.
So it works or it
doesn't work on the basis
of how much rpduct did shift?
It's very easy to analyze.
Public Relations, on the
other hand, creates stories.
It tells you who people
are and what they do
and why they're passionate
about their business,
and why you should
actually invest in them.
I often think public relations
people are like doctors.
Because they work
from a goody bag.
but the goody bag has
loads of tools in them.
So if you go to a doctor
and you have a cough,
the doctor may say to you,
meh, it's a bit of a cough.
It's no big deal.
You need a cough bottle.
The doctor may
equally look at you
and say, oh, I don't like the
sound of that cough at all.
OK, I need you get x-rays.
Last time I heard somebody
with a cough like that,
I never saw them a second time.
Or the doctor may well
lookat you and say,
you're a malingerer.
There's nothing wrong with you.
Go back to work.
I'm not giving
you a certificate.
But he dips into a
goody bag of tools
and say, here's what you need.
PR people do exactly
the same thing.
We look at a business
and we say, OK,
if you're trying to
communicate with people,
which tool do you need to use?
So should you be
using exhibitions?
Should you be using e-zines?
Should you be
using social media?
using sponsorships?
What's the tool
that will work best
for each different audience?
Because you won't reach
everybody with the same tool.
So this book is
about 10 of the tools
that I believe are most
relevant to people in SMEs.
Before I move onto them, I
should mention the word spin.
Because every time you hear
the word public relations,
you hear spin.
And PR people have this huge
thing about, we do not spin.
We are not spin doctors.
We are in public relations.
I was introduced about
three or four years ago
as the princess of
the dark art of spin.
I absolutely adored it.
I have dined out
on it ever since.
Because I think that
is exactly what we do.
Businesses do it, people do it.
I wore a suit this morning.
I'm serious about
being an author.
That's my spin.
I could've come in
in a pair of jeans.
You would've had an entirely
different visual spin.
You chose to dress exactly
the way you chose this morning
because it says something
about you, the mood you're in,
what you want to project to
people in the world today.
That's spin.
That's a visual spin.
We also do it by text.
So there are two
ways you can spin.
One is visually.
What you look like
says something.
It creates an expectation.
But equally, text
does the same thing.
Let me give you an example.
If I said that my best
friend is a drug addict,
what immediately
comes into your head?
What does drug addict say?
AUDIENCE: Pills.
AUDIENCE: She takes drugs.
AUDIENCE: Hypodermic needles?
ELLEN GUNNING:
Pills, Takes drugs.
A bit down and out.
Not really the best, probably
in a bad place right now.
Needs to feed a
habit, so God only
knows how they actually get
enough money to feed the habit.
The whole "drug addict," just
the use of the words "drug
addict" says, mm, I wouldn't
have thought she associated
with those kinds of people.
If, on the other hand,
I said, my best friend
is a recreational user, you'd
go whoa, too many parties.
Too much white stuff.
Got to cut back on that stuff.
It'll kill you eventually.
It's a whole different spin.
You're still talking about
somebody who uses drugs.
But it's a spin.
It's a textual spin.
Your head creates a
different picture.
And that's what PR people do.
They say, don't look over there.
Look over here.
That's what spin is about.
It's not about telling a lie.
It's about diverting your
attention just a little bit.
So visual spin, let me look at
four of the 10 Red Hot Tips,
possibly, that are
included in this.
Visual, photo calls, we
live in a visual era.
Look at the way we watch
news, and the way news
is presented to us,
how it's changed
in the last 10 or 15 years.
If you looked at
news years ago, it
was one person sitting to a
camera on television saying,
here is the news, and
you had a clip behind.
If you watch news
on television now,
you've got all these
boxes coming down
the side with short little
breaking pieces of news.
You've got ticker tape
running underneath.
Nobody actually sits there
and waits for the next story.
We have no patience.
But the visual
tells us something.
It's like this morning, there
was an avalanche in Italy.
I've seen the avalanche.
I know what ahppened.
It's a visual kind of thing.
If you can create a really good
visual, people will remember.
They associate it
with your business.
There are two ways to do
it. one is by photo call,
and one is by photo shoot.
Photo call is where you
actually invite all of the media
to attend.
And you set up the
picture for them.
Photo shoot is where you
create the photograph,
and you send it to the media.
So let me give you
example of both.
I must warn you in advance,
small, little people,
vertically challenged,
generally called children,
I don't have any of them.
I find it very difficult
to communicate with them.
OK?
We need to contextualize
this story, OK?
So I have a guy that was
vertically challenged.
Until they're my height
and make eye contact
and speak in fully-formed
sentences they're like,
nice to meet you kid, move on.
OK?
So I'm doing this
photo call and it's
for the opening of a school.
It's a day school.
And I have two children, a
photographer sitting beside me.
And he says, OK, what I want to
get is that traditional shot.
I want to get a little boy,
little girl holding hands,
walking to school, day one.
I thought, easy.
I told you, I have no kids.
OK?
So I was scrambling.
Two?
There's a little boy.
There, that little girl there.
So yeah, they look nice.
Sean, do me a favor and
hold Maureen's hand please.
(ALTERED VOICE) No.
I'm not doing it.
Right.
Maureen, hold
Sean's hand please.
(ALTERED VOICE) Oh, OK.
And she puts her hand in.
And he goes, (ALTERED
VOICE) I'm not doing it.
Able Well, we go through this
about two or three times.
I said to the photographer, this
kid has an attitude problem.
He's not going to hold her hand.
And he said, no, and we're
not going to get the shot.
I said, no, no,
we'll get the shot.
I just need to lose the child.
OK?
So without even
thinking, I turn around.
Now, I'm in the zone.
So I turned around and said,
who owns the little boy?
And the photographer turns
back to me and went, who owns?
Who owns the little boy?
I'm dead.
I'm going to record
this on film.
Somebody is going to kill you.
You do not own a child.
And this father came thundering
over the group, like a lunatic.
And he goes, I'm Sean's father.
And I still haven't
really registered
what the photographer said.
So I said, great.
Do me a favor, will you?
The photographer's trying to get
a shot for "The Irish Times."
The kid won't cooperate.
I just want him
to hold her hand.
He won't do it.
Sorry, but that
kid has his chance.
He's gone.
I need to put another little
boy in, in place of him.
I don't do tactful, either.
I should have mentioned.
What was the father's reaction?
Any idea?
AUDIENCE: Defensive?
AUDIENCE: He made the
kid hold her hand.
ELLEN GUNNING: Told the
child to hold hands?
He had the child sideways.
He goes, Sean!
You hold her hand
right-by-God now!
Because all the father
heard was "Irish Times."
He didn't hear the child's
being uncooperative.
He didn't hear who
owns the child?
He heard "Irish
Times," and my child.
And we got the front
page of "The Irish Times"
the next day, with the child.
The little girl going, eh.
And the little boy, rawr!
But it was a classic shot.
If you'd pinch the child, you
couldn't have set it up better.
[LAUGHTER]
YOu're learning a lot
about the way I work.
Probably more than
you needed to know.
From the school's point of
view, what they wanted was,
they were looking for a
bit of publicity to say,
the school has opened.
It's a new school.
It's in this area.
And they ended up was front
page of the "Irish Times,"
with a shot that said, this
is the new school that opened.
And it was outside of Dublin.
So the chances of actually
getting that kind of publicity
were unreal.
But it was a great photograph.
So if you take a great shot,
people will look at it.
And they remember it.
The exmple that I used in the
book was from Butler's Pantry.
You all familiar
with Butler's Pantry?
Butler's Pantry, probably
the best way to describe it,
it's like a gourmet food outlet.
You're probably in
there if you want
to buy really good quality,
fresh, homemade food
on your way home in the evening.
They're kind of
like, do you know
the way Marks & Spencers
do those food ads?
You know the way you could've
completely eaten an entire meal
and you're stuffed and thinking,
I never want to see food again?
And a Marks & Spencers food
ad comes on and you go,
that looks lovely.
Then suddenly
you're hungry again.
Food, if you're going
to promote food,
you have promote food
with that yumminess.
And Butler's Pantry bring in
a professional photographer
each time they take photographs.
But because photography
is so expensive,
and it's probably only
about half the price that it
was five or six years ago.
Five or six years
ago, before the crash,
if you brought in a photograph
to do any photo shoot,
you said to the client,
you need 1,200 to 1,500.
You won't get out.
You won't get
change out of that.
Now we're looking at
somewhere around 300 to 600.
So it's a big change.
But for a small
business, you're still
looking at bringing
in a photograph
to take a photograph.
And I dont' know if
anybody will use it.
So I have a really
good-quality photograph,
but will it be used?
And what Butler's Pantry do is
they trial all the photographs.
So if they're doing a new,
I don't know, salmon dish,
they storyboard
the entire thing.
So this is how we would
like to promote salmon.
This is what we want
people to think and feel.
When we say salmon, we
people to go, oh, salmon.
I haven't had salmon
in a long time.
Fresh fish,
gorgeous, [INAUDIBLE]
of knowledge, whatever it is.
And then they try to
create the photograph.
So they spend days
seeing what works best?
Should I put this here?
Should I put that there?
How, exactly, do
we mix the people?
The groups together.
And when they think they
have it exactly right,
then they get the
photographer in.
And the photographer
literally shoots it.
But the photographs
that they take
have been used for up
to five years, which
is a very long time
to get out of a photo.
But it's good value.
But their attitude is, if
they spend that much money,
they really want to be sure
before the photographer comes
in the door that it's giving the
message that they want it to.
And that's a visual message.
And that's public relations.
That's a photo call.
The second area I wanted
to look at was sponsorship.
Because people seem to
think that sponsorship
is all about having
lots of money.
Everybody knows
the big sponsorhips
because they're in your face.
They've got huge
budgets behind them.
Sponsorship can work
really, really well
for a small-to-medium-size
enterprise.
But it only works really
well if, like everything else
you do in life, you
put time into it
and you think it through.
So let me give you two
examples of sponsorship,
one good and one bad.
The example I used
in the book was
a company called Action Coach.
Action Coach worked with
small-to-medium-size
enterprises.
And their job is that they
basically go into companies
and they teach them how
to be more competitive.
So that may be how to take
risks in certain markets.
Or they may say to them,
look, your targeted market
is far too broad.
You're never going
to reach everybody.
You need to try a
little bit tighter.
Or it may be that you just
don't know what you're
doing, in terms of money.
So we need to actually
teach you a little bit more
about profit and loss,
and how to manage money
and how to look after cash flow.
And basically, they work
with small business,
trying to get them
to the next step.
They're based in Ballymun.
And they're very passionate
about being in Ballymun,
and what can they do
for people in Ballymun?
And I'm going to be shot at.
There's a rugby player--
I'm hopeless on sports--
who's from Ballymun.
Does anybody know who
I'm talking about?
Anyway, or he could
be a golf player.
Anyway, there's a guy who's
a very well-known sports
person from Ballymun.
And they met him
at a talk one day.
Literally, they were just
sitting, listening to him talk.
And he was talking
about the fact
that he'd come from Ballymun.
His family were very poor.
He'd done very well.
He was looking to give
something back to the area.
It started them thinking.
They developed a board game.
The board game teaches you how
to deal with profit and loss,
how to look after cash
flow, how to take risks,
how to analyze risks.
And they decided
what they would do,
is they would work
with local schools.
And they would go
into local schools
and create a competition,
but teach children
how to build up these skills.
And they objective was twofold.
One was that they might
actually find that they've
an iotnerest in commerce
or becoming enterepreneurs,
or owning their own
business. but the second
was that if they
never did, they'd
have developed skills which
were useful for the rest
of their lives.
And that's a really good
example of sponsorship.
Another example, by
comparison, you're
in what we all call
Googleland now.
But I used to live around
the corner, on Ringsend road.
So I don't know whether
you should be welcoming me
to Googleland or I should be
thanking you for inviting me
back home again.
But I've lived on Ringsend Road.
And I was very involved in
the community in Ringsend.
Because I lived
there all my life.
I got married, moved
away, came back
to live there when
I was married.
I only moved out
about 15 years ago.
And I just love being
involved in community.
Because I think
it's who we all are.
We don't have enough community
involvement, whether it's
community of interest,
or physical community
in which we live.
We had a Glamourous
Granny competition
quite a few years ago.
And the Glamorous
Granny competition
was sponsored by the
local beauticians, which I
thought was a really nice fit.
It was clever.
The Glamourous
Grannies all came in.
And they ranged in age.
At that time, I've gone
back probably 20 years,
from 55 to 75.
Now they range in
age from 35 to 75.
But they ranged in age
from about 55 to 75.
So most of the ladies came in.
And they had that
lovely gray, buffed hair
that looked like they'd
just taken the curlers out.
You know that look
that people have?
Who
And they came up and they sang.
They talked about their
three children and their two
grandchildren, and how old they
were and what their names were.
Very nice, very
pleasant evening.
All of the husbands, by
the way, who were alive,
came in and stood.
Only came in for
"her" bit, and came in
and stood at the
end of the hall,
watch her, and went that's
fine, and went back off,
out for a pint
again, and wouldn't
stay for the rest of the night.
But they did their bit.
They did it really well.
And the beauticians was ggiving
the prize for whatever it was.
200 euros worth of goods
in the beauticians.
They sent in a young model
to present the pirze.
So you've got a roomful
of people who are
55, 75 years age, all female.
And they send in this
absolutely drop-dead
gorgeous-looking girl.
She was tall.
She was stick-insect thin.
She was on heels
this high, like she
was teetering on Jimmy Choos.
She walked the way models do.
They kind of walk like
cats on high heels.
And she strutted her stuff
all the way up the stage.
She looked amazing.
She came up and she
presented all of the prizes.
And what everybody did in the
audience, as she walked past,
was say, oh my god, look at
the height of those heels.
Can you remember ever
wearing heels that high?
Oh yeah, but it was before
I had my first child.
Never wore heels
that high since.
Look at her little waist.
She's a size 8.
It'd say she's a size 10.
[GASPS]
I was never a size 10.
The smallest I
ever was was a 12.
And actually what they did
was they reminded people
of what it was like
to be young or single,
or before they had children.
They brought them
back to their 20s.
They did not target them
as 55-to-75-year-olds.
What they should have
done, in my opinion,
was they should have got
somebody who was either
very well-known in
the community who
was of that age, or the
previous winner, the last year,
and brought her in
and pampered her.
So that somebody in their 60s
or 70s preseneted the prize.
And instead of saying,
look at her little waist,
and do you remember
those high heels?
You would actually say, my
god, look at the change in her?
Doesn't she look amazing?
Actually, this is what the
beauticians did because it then
reminds people, it makes
the association with people.
And that, to my idea, would
have been a good sponsorship.
They actually misfired.
They sponsored, they
put the money into it.
They sent somebody in
to present the prizes.
I doubt that anybody
even connected the two.
It's not about selling.
But I doubt that anybody
walked past and said,
that's the beauticians
that sponsored.
Because they didn't
make that connection.
So sponsorship,
very little money.
The other thing
with sponsorship,
just as I think of it, when
we moved back into Ringsend,
we moved back after
oh, I don't know.
I'd grown up and lived
there till I was about 18.
And I moved back about
oh, probably 25 years ago.
And when I moved
back, they were still
delivering milk to the door.
But I'm what everybody
calls a yuppy.
So I'm gone early
morning in the morning
and I'm back late
in the evening.
Ilove the way Ringsenders always
have their own pronunciations
and everything.
Dubliners do it
as a general rule.
So I was gone early in the day.
And literally, it
got to the stage
where you'd come outside
the door in the morning
and go, oh, for God's
sake, there's no milk.
Or you come out and go, yippe
ki-yay, we have milk today.
And it drove me insane.
So at one stage I met with
one of the neighbors and said,
well, do me a favor.
If you see the milkman,
find out what I owe him.
Pay him off.
Tell him thanks very much.
I'm going to just get
the milk as I need it.
And she said, really?
What'd the milkman do on you?
What's the problem
with the milkman?
And I said, there's no
problem with the milkman.
It's just that the
milk is there some days
and it's not there other days.
And she said, oh I
see, Ms. Gunning.
Oh yeah, yeah.
We're not all like
you, you know.
We don't all leave in the
middle of the night, come back
in the middle of the night.
That poor man gets
up at four o'clock
in the morning to
deliver the milk.
I said, I know.
But he should be
getting up at 3:30.
Free Because I don't get
the milk outside the door.
She said, I'll tell
you what I'll do.
When I'm passing
by, if there's milk
outside your door in
the morning, I'll take
and I'll put it into the shop.
And I'll keep it cold for you.
And you can collect it from
the shop in the evning.
I said, just think about this.
This is not logical.
He jumps outof the van,
leaves me the milk.
You come by and go
oh look, there's
the milk-- because I've already
left-- and brings it down
to the shop.
It's just crazy.
Just pay the guy off and
tell me how much I owe.
And she said, no, no, no.
You don't understand.
This man goes out of his way.
He's been delivering milk in
this area for years and years.
And he goes out of his way
to sponsor the local soccer
club every year.
He buys them a whole
section of jerseys.
I thought it was a brilliant
example of somebody who
had connected to the community.
I wasn't connected.
I didn't have kids.
I didn't respectwhat
this man was doing.
What she did and the
whole community did,
and that's why we
buy our milk fromhim.
The man has to earn a living.
And he's very good.
And he doesn't have
to buy these T-shirts.
And it really brought
it home that sponsorship
had such a long-term impact
on people around you.
That man was getting
business because people
who were grandparents or
people like me who had no kids
were told, he's
earning his lving.
He's contributing
to the community.
So good sponsorships.
Well, I don't know what it
cost him for a set of jerseys
for a football team.
But it wasn't a huge
amount of money.
But he got the return out of it
year on year, on year on year.
So sponsorship, second one.
Third one is exhibitions.
The number of people who
don't use exhibitions
properly-- exhibitions,
you're going to pay to attend.
So you've decided as
a business that this
is where you should be.
But the number of businesses
who don't then follow through--
if you book an exhibition and
you book it early, if you know
in January that you're doing
an exhibition in September,
what happens is that people send
you out all of these notices.
The exhibition organizers
send you notices and say,
so will you be doing anything
different at the exhibition?
Are you launching
anything extraoridnry?
Do you have any unusual guests?
is there anything you want to
tell us about your stall that
makes it different?
Small-to-medium-size
enterprises,
because they're busy, look
at it and go, for God's sake,
how do I know in Januaray what
I'm going to do in September?
So they leave it.
They just throw it to one side
and say, I'll do it later.
And then come August, they
fill in all the information.
And whoever was
organizing has already
decided who gets the publicity.
Because in January or February,
the organizer is saying,
I need to know where my
stories are coming from.
So if you take the
trouble to tell me
that you're doing something
different, I'll promote you.
So it's free PR that's sitting
there, waiting for them.
But people don't
actually take the time
to do it because they need
to move so much earlier.
And really, if they
did, they'd have
a whole team of professional
people promoting them.
It's a no-brainer.
It should make sense.
I was on an exhibition
for TY students, students
and teachers, last year, just
before the book came out.
And there was a company called
High Rock Productions, who had
taken an exhibition stand out.
And the exhibition was huge.
It was in this massive
warehouse in Carlow somewhere.
We came into the warehouse.
And every single
stand has something
for transitionary students.
So you had, "Learn to
Climb the [INAUDIBLE],,
we'll teach you how to
make presentation skills,
come kayaking with us--
whole loads of it-- we
teach you first aid.
A mix between the
skills that you
would use as an
individual and things
that you went out
and did as groups.
And this particular group,
High Rock Productions,
I stopped because when
I came round the corner,
there was an entire
square closed off.
Now, what they actually
do is they go into schools
and they help
children speak Irish.
So they prep them for
their oral Irish exams.
But they do it by
creating this play.
So it's very creative.
They work with the children.
They create this play.
And when they've made this
play, they help to put it on.
It's all true Irish.
So they become more confident
about speaking the language.
Very hard thing to promote
to children, most of whom
probably haven't an interest
in and oral Irish and "exams,"
and they're looking at
TY, which is the year
in between their exams.
So they're not focusing on it.
And what this group had done
was they had taken a square.
They had about three
times the amount of space
that they should have had.
So they'd taken a square
in from of the stand.
And they closed it off.
And they were playing
virtual tennis.
It was absolutely brilliant.
Because one of the guys was
tehre and he was saying, OK,
are you ready?
Serve-- step off
the court, please.
You're on the court.
Get off the court.
And as people walked
past, they went, here?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Am I OK?
Back, back, back.
And everybody got it.
There was nothing.
There was absolutely nothing.
But everybody go it
and they stood back.
And when the ball went out of
play, they would say, sorry,
could I have the ball there?
Yeah.
No, no, at your other foot.
There?
Yeah.
Can you throw it?
Thank you.
Yeah, got it.
And everybody stopped to watch.
It was brilliant.
It took a huge amount of
attention to their side.
And they gave everybody
leaflets about what they did.
I thought it was
really, really clever.
When I interviewed
them afterwards,
I said, by the way,
brilliant idea.
You took over so
much space, lads.
Smart.
And they said, yeah,
but I'm not sure it was
as smart as it could've been.
Because it targeted
all of the children.
And their query was that
the exhibition was targeted
to both children and teachers.
And with hindsight,
they weren't sure
if you could target
both in one exhibition.
And what they had done
was they had successfully
got all of the children involed.
But the children didn't decide
what they would do in TY year.
The teachers did.
So they'd actually misfired.
They got loads of attention.
They got loads of kids
talking about them.
But they didn't have the teacher
saying, what a good idea.
And people didn't
connect virtual tennis
with what they were
actually doing.
So it was interesting,
because to my eyes, coming in
as an outsider, I
thought, very smart.
You've captured the whole room.
When they analyzed it
aftweard they thought,
good btu not as brilliant
as it could've been.
I suppose one of the things that
I'm really conscious of the PR
is that it's not rocket science.
It does take a lot of time.
But most of the skills
can be easily learned.
But it's about not
doing things on the fly.
Because PR doesn't
respond well to things
that are done on the fly.
You end up saying
why didn't that work?
I've put loads of time
into it on short notice.
It works really well
if you sit down early
and say, who am I
trying to reach?
What am I trying to acheive?
How do I get them?
What are they interested in?
One of the very clever companies
that I profiled in the book
was Newbridge Silver.
I'm a big believer in
third-party endorsement.
If you stand up and say I
run a wonderful business.
That's a marvelous business.
Everybody here just
loves what they do.
We provide great quality
product, or whwatever.
Everybody would say, well, you
would say that, wouldn't you?
Which is fair enough,
because you're not going say,
I run a rubbish business.
Who was the guy who did that?
His junior business went bust.
There was a man who famously
said he just produces
junk jewelry and people buy it.
And the entire business went
bust very shortly afterwards.
Because everybody said, well,
I buy that junk jewelry.
And he thinks it's junk?
Why do I waste my
time buying it.
But as a general
rule, you're looking
at third-party endorsement is
where somebody says of you,
it's good.
Or where you create
an association.
And Newbridge are very clever
at creating the association.
They came up with this
idea of style ambassadors.
So instead of it
just being jewelry,
they started using
people like Amy Huberman
and Naomi Campbell and
Ronan O'Gara, and saying,
OK, these are people who you
can associate with our jewelry.
Interestingly enough,
they used Linda Gray.
You know the lady from "Dallas?"
That's interesting.
How many people actually know
Linda Gray from "Dallas?"
Very few.
Excellent.
Thank you.
It makes my point.
Because she was introduced
on "The Late Late" years ago,
when they started using her
And she was wearing big,
chunky Newbridge jewelry.
Now,
Now, she's a fabulous woman.
She was about in her
70's at the time.
You would've given her
like, 52 at the most.
She looked amazing.
And she was wearing
this chunky jewelry.
And you looked and
thought, she actually
isn't the type of person
who wears chunky jewelry.
If she had been doing Newbridge
Cutlery, dining at home,
and here's how the
posh dine, it probably
would've sat much more easily.
But doing chukny
jewelry at her age,
even though she was glamourous,
didn't seem to work.
But it did work very well
with the likes of Amy Huberman
and Naomi Campbell.
And what they do is they
associate the people
with the product.
So if they're stylish and
tehy wear our product,
you should do the same.
Very interestingly, when I spoke
to the lady who coordinates,
their brand ambassadors,
I said to them,
it must be very difficult.
Because I innocently assumed
that if you were Amy Huberman
and you were wearing Newbridge,
that as Newbridge you
would say, by the
way, sweet pea,
I do not want you wearing
anybody else's jewelry
because we're paying
you shedloads of money.
So I expect to see
you in Newbridge only.
And she said, oh God, no.
No, no, no.
Because nobody who follows Amy
Huberman will believe that.
They would know that of
course she has her own style
and she wears any one of a
number of different things.
So when she chooses
to wear Newbridge,
we're happy that she does so.
But when she chooses
to wear somebody else,
we're equally happy.
And I thought it
was very clever.
Because it then
doesn't look like we
pay you to wear this
jewelry all the time.
It looks like yes, you're
a brand ambassador,
but when you feel
like wearing it.
And she actually
wore a long chain.
When she announced that she
was expecting her second child,
she wore a long Newbridge chain.
And she tweeted because
she's a mad tweeter.
And she tweeted
something about the coat.
I can't remember.
"Bump by BOD, chain
by Newbridge."
And they sold out.
They had no idea she
was going to do it.
They knew when she was
doing the photo, apparently,
that she was pregnant.
But she didn't want to
say anything about it.
And when she
eventually tweeted it,
it was just like it's her call.
It's her baby.
So she tweeted it.
They weren't expecting it.
They sold out of the chain.
They went into a
second production
and sold out of the
as well, the number
of people who
just wanted to buy that chain.
So the association from
their point of view
worked really well.
They associated with people
that people want to look like,
or people want to emulate.
And they followed that through
with the Museum of Style Icons.
So they actually have all
of these clothes, which
are actually, if you've
been down to see them,
the clothes are moth
eaten and it's incredible,
how old the clothes are.
But they were Audrey Hepburn's.
Or they were--
who's the lady who
went to become Princess
Grace of Monacco?
Grace Kelly.
So you end up looking at these
clothes thinking, wow, that's
what people acutally wore.
Did anybody go down for the
Michael Jackson exhibition,
by the way?
They had Michael
Jackson's clothes.
You know the famous
glove, the sparkly glove?
They had it.
I just decided I had to go down.
You never saw anything
like the trousers.
I actually said to
sombody, are they real?
The trousers were
about this wide.
My god, he was tiny.
A size eight would
have been giant.
He was absolutely tiny.
But they actually
made that association.
And it's clever.
It's an association with
style, with glamour.
You call in.
You buy some of the product.
You've made the link.
Very, very smart.
And they also work with Audrey
Hepburn's and Grace Kelly's
Foundation.
So that they approve
whatever it is
that they design that they use.
So this would have
been the kind of thing
that Grace Kelly
would have used.
So it carries her name with it.
Very, very smart.
Much simpler third-party
endorsement, if you like,
when I was talking about
the book to Bobby Kerr
on "Newstalk," he had said
to me, OK, what I'll do
is I'll just use the
examples that we used.
And I said sure, I don't mind.
Ask me abotu anything
that's in the book.
I'm happy to talk about it.
So he actually talked
about Jackie Martin.
Then he talked about
Jack Murray's company.
I mean, it's a what, 10
or 12-minute interview?
So we went trhough the
interview and we chatted.
And I ssaid, oh
this guy's crazy.
If you go into his office, the
walls are papered with paper.
And every piece of paper has
this tweet, how many retweets?
What was the reach?
Is it worth doing?
Did it work?
Should we do it again?
He data mines within
an inch of his life.
And it just seems so
strange that it's all
on paper around the walls.
But I presume it's
because it surrounds him
and it reminds him,
this is what we are.
This is what we do.
Did the interview.
Happy out.
Promotion for the book.
My job was done.
That was on a Saturday.
On Sunday, as I was
driving somewhere,
I got a text from Jack
to say, thanks very much
for the kind words about
my business yesterday.
I knew his father was ill.
And he said, unfortunately,
my father has died.
And somebody heard the interview
on the way to the funeral,
and very kind of you to
say such nice things.
And I thought, that's
very decent of him to text
and let me know.
So I said, sorry to
hear about your dad.
And thanks for the comments.
And then on the following
Friday, I came into the office.
And there's this
huge box of cupcakes.
So I said oh, lads,who's
sending us cupcakes?
And he said, us?
Us?
It specifically
says, Ellen Gunnings.
Oh, it's all about me.
Who's sending me cupcakes?
And inside was a note.
There was a dozen cupcakes and a
note from the same Jack saying,
Ellen, thank you very much
for all of the comments
on "Newtalk."
You wouldn't believe
how much business
we got out the back of it.
Best regards, Jack.
I wasn't promoting his business.
I wasn't flogging his business.
I wasn't advertising it.
I was just saying, he's
really good at what he does.
And that's a
third-party endorsement.
That's somebody else saying
it with no axe to grind.
And that is very, very powerful.
And that's something,
actually, that you in Google
can do very easily.
You work with SMEs.
You've already gone
through who they are.
You've cross checked them.
You think they have
something of value
that you can invest your time or
your money or your energy into.
Is there a way that you
can actually say to people,
do you know what?
There is a way
that you can brand.
You can say brand
Google works with you.
So that they can take that
to other people and say,
it's not just me saying
I know what I'm at.
Google believes I know what
I'm at, so just to leave you
with that thought.
There are six other
hot tips in the book.
I'm happy to go through
all of them if you wish.
But I might actually give
you a chance, because you're
sitting quietly, nodding.
And I'm much more comfortable
when people are interrupting
the hell out of me.
So I might let you ask a few
questions and see what happens.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Thanks.
ELLEN GUNNING: Thanks a million.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Thanks a million, Ellen.
That was fantastic, wasn't it?
[APPLAUSE]
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: So
will we jump straight in?
Does anyone have
a burning question
that they'd like to ask?
We've got two microphones
to pass around.
ELLEN GUNNING: Burning
questions are really good.
Nothing normal.
Go for it.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
OK, so while you're
building up some confidence
and trying to think about it,
I'd like to know, Ellen, you
touched on it very briefly
about your audience and
considering who exactly
am I trying to reach?
So other than just asking
yourself those really specific
questions, what else can
we be asking ourselves?
Or how else can we really
answer that question?
ELLEN GUNNING: I think the
trap most people fall into,
we all look to reach people
using the same methods
that we used.
So if I read "The
Irish Times," I
assume that everybody
I want to reach
will read "The Irish Times."
If I live on social
media, I assume they all
live on social media.
What happens is we forget
to look at the other side.
I call it where people feed.
I atteneded a conference
a few years back.
And the guy talked
about chasing pigeons.
I don't know if you've
heard this story before.
It was brilliant.
And he talked about
if you chase pigeons.
If you try to feed pigeons
and you chase them in a park,
the pigeons fly away.
Like, go away.
Stop chasing me.
You're bothering me.
Watch the old man who
sits down on the park seat
and he just keeps
dropping crumbs.
And the pigeons come to him.
And it's about knowing, what
are the pigeons looking for?
Bread.
They're not looking for hassle.
They'll come to you.
And the more often they come to
you, the more they trust you.
And they more you build
up their confidence.
With any kind of an
audience, your problem
is that you look at them
from the inside out.
You should look
from the outside in.
The chances are,
with any business,
you actually need to use--
they said originally, when radio
was overtaken by television
or when television
was invented, they
said it was the death of radio.
When newspapers
gave in, they said
it was the death
of something else.
When socieal media came in,
they said, oh that's it.
People will only
use social media.
It's actually not true.
We did an interview
at the weekend.
We're teaching a TV
presenters course.
And we were doing
mock interviews
in advance of the way the
thing for the show is.
Students were just
interviewing each other.
They're all adults.
They're all over 20-odd.
And [INAUDIBLE],,
who was leading it,
said to one of the girls,
what are you interseted in?
And she said, acting.
And he said to the
other girl, brilliant.
So ask her about Meryl
Streep's speech, Donald Trump
retweeting, the Golden Globes,
all that kind of stuff.
It was fascinating to watch.
So Meryl Streep's speech--
you are all familiar that
Marilyn Streep made a speech?
OK, just checking.
Meryl Streep's speech at the
Golden Globes, what did you
think of it.
And she said oh, I don't know.
I didn't hear it.
What was it about?
And she OK.
And she gave her a very
quick explanaation.
And she said, uh--
and Donald Trump
retweeted, you know,
"the most overrated actress
in America," or whatever.
And she said, yeah,
I didn't see that.
And she said, OK, well, what
do you think about the fact
that the President-elect is
tweeting about an actress?
And she said, I don't know.
I haven't seen any of it.
I have no idea.
I catch up on all my social
media on Sunday mornings.
And it was eye-opening.
It was like,
everybody in the room
assumed everybody had
heard Meryl Streep.
How could you miss it?
Because it had been tackled
from so many different angles.
And in her world,
Sunday morning was when
she caught up on everything.
So it's looking at your audience
from their point of view
and saying, if they're
Sunday newspaper readers,
then that's where
you need to get them.
It doesn't matter that you
can be all over social media.
They don't find you.
It's they're social
media people, then where?
What bloggers do
they actually read?
Who influences them?
Who do they think is rubbish?
Who do they think is brilliant?
If it's radio, which radio
stations do they listen to?
So are they "Newtalk"
listeners or RTE 1 listeners?
It's a different listener.
You tune to the dial and
you stay, more or less,
on the dial if you're
of a certain age group.
And then if you're of a
certain age group as well,
do you actually go
hunting for information?
Or does it come
into you by email?
So it's really breaking
down your audience,
and probably choosing
a different tune
for ech subsection.
That's a very long answer
to a very short question.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's great.
ELLEN GUNNING: Sorry.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: No,
that's a great answer.
Thank you very much.
We've got a question
here, don't we?
AUDIENCE: I was thinking, first
of all, thanks for the talk.
I was thinking in
terms of sponsorships.
I think most of us here are
ex-pats or not from Ireland.
So we're that deep
into the community,
as some of the initial
examples that you had.
What would be some
of the easy ways
to get into getting
a sponsorship,
or getting in touch with people?
What would be some of
the first couple of steps
to getting into sponsorships?
ELLEN GUNNING: To actually find
something that's sponsoring,
I would go the other
way around with it.
If you're not from Ireland,
I would choose something
that was unique to you.
So it might be Brazilian
movies or something.
And you think, OK.
Have a look at the
community and see where
is there a community week?
And if there's a community
week, is there a role
in there somewhere for movies?
And as part of the movies,
we can show Brazilian movies.
It depends on what
the connection
is that you're trying to make.
But it also sets you up.
You're the logical connection.
So you can actually
introduce yourself and say,
I'm Brazilian.
That's why I'm passionate
about Brazilian movies.
You never would've guessed.
And people will go,
oh, is that why?
Because people won't
make a connection
unless you tell them.
That's the other thing.
They will say you're an
"ex-pat," or whatever.
You're not Irish, but they
won't know where you're from.
So I would look for something
that is close to your heart,
that you're an expert in,
that you can offer to sponsor.
But it's more work.
It means that you need to set
it up, create it, and run it.
But if you do, people will come.
When I did the first
Active Age week,
everybody told me that
I was wasting my time.
And if I was looking
at creating things
for senior citizens, what they
were interested in was bingo.
So if I did bingo--
[LAUGHTER]
Honest to God.
So if I did bingo seven nights
a week, they'd be happier.
And I said, look at this face.
Does this look like a face
that ever played bingo?
Or has any desire to
create bingo nights?
Not happening.
But what I will do, is
I'll do one night of bingo.
But I will do everything
else around it.
And if nobody comes to
anything, there's my butt.
You can kick it and say, I
told you, you're [INAUDIBLE]..
You were wrong.
And we did historical nights.
We did boat trips.
We did mystery trips
out into the country.
We did afternoons where
people just came in
and somebody played
piano and they all sang.
We were blocked out
every single night.
There was standing room only.
At every single function.
And they all turned
up for bingo as well.
But nobody said at the end
of the week, what a pity it
wasn't all bingo.
So I think if you
actually find something
that you're passionate
about, that you can create,
people will come, and it
will make the association.
It also give you a niche
that nobody else has.
The other thing
with sponsorship is,
if you come in to sponsor
after somebody has been there,
it takes a long time to lose
the last sponsor's name.
So the general rule is that if
you're doing a sponsorhip deal,
it should be for three years.
And you should an extra two.
So you've a facility that
nobody else can step in
for the next two.
You get first dibs on it.
But after five, you should move
on and inspect your audience
again.
Because after five, if you're
targeting 17-year-olds,
the 17-year-olds are
now 18, 19, 20, or 22.
They're no longer interested
in the same things.
They've moved onto
something else.
But after five years, your
name stays for at least two.
So the next sponsor
coming in has an awful job
branding their name onto
whatever it is they're doing.
So I'd go the other route, and
create it with your name on it
and let them follow you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is [? Sezgi. ?]
I'm working in sales team--
in Google Marketing Solutions
team.
In fact, mine is not a question.
It's just inspiration from you.
It was very, very eye-opening.
At Google, we try--
at Google's sales team,
we try to increase
our share [INAUDIBLE] from our
clients' [INAUDIBLE] business.
But today, you gave me
another amazing idea--
why we are going to
try and to increase
our budget on the team, our
clients may [INAUDIBLE]..
Also, we can have payer share
from our client's PR budget
as well, if you can position
Google products as PR
solutions.
It was very, very
eye-opening, and it
was a huge leverage
for my business,
when I'm [INAUDIBLE]
back to my desk 100%.
I will do meetings.
I will organize meetings
with my clients' PR managers.
And I will talk
about you to them,
and can use for their PRs.
ELLEN GUNNING: And I just want--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ELLEN GUNNING: --half a
percent of that business.
That's all.
[LAUGHTER]
But actually, you're right,
because advertising very often
is part of a promotional plan.
So you can do a huge amount of
PR that actually gets you out
there and gets your product
or your brand known.
But it gets to the
stage where you say,
now we need to sell it.
But you will still
use PR to enhance.
Part of it is the
straight selling,
and the other is you simply
turning over to people
and say, oh, I saw an
ad for that somewhere.
So, brilliant.
Let me know how
you get on with it.
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
ELLEN GUNNING: I
can brag about you.
We can have a mutual loving.
Excellent.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have a question.
Coming back to your milkman
story, that very inspiring.
But my thought was that
probably the milkman
didn't realize the effect
that the sponsorship has.
ELLEN GUNNING: I'm
sure he didn't.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is if an SME at this size
is to do a PR investment,
what kind of advice
can you give defining
what success is?
ELLEN GUNNING: It depends
on what you're actually
trying to achieve.
So, what sponsorship is best
at is creating name awareness.
If you look at any of
the great sponsorships
they started because people
were moving into new markets,
or they had changed their name.
So the company was no
longer known as one thing.
It was now known
as something else.
When-- who sponsored the first
cycle race around Ireland?
Was it Toyota?
And they sponsored it
because it's a car company.
Doesn't make sense
that a car company
would sponsor cycle races.
It was at the time when Stephen
Roche and all of those guys
were winning medals.
But it was because Toyota
used to be called--
was it Toyota who used
to be called Datsun?
And people didn't
know the brand.
So the whole idea
was, if you create
an awareness of the brand,
people say, I've heard of you.
And what's the story?
It opens the door a bit.
So what sponsorship is best at
is creating brand awareness.
So if you're an SME,
and you're trying
to make people conscious of
the fact that you're around,
sponsorship is very good at it.
But you need to do
your before and after.
Most people will tell you--
if you ask people in
Google, how many people
have heard of Google?
Well, Google's
probably a bad example.
You're like, oh my god, the
whole world's heard of Google.
Is there anybody
left in the world?
There's a couple of
people [INAUDIBLE]
I believe who haven't
heard of us yet,
but everybody has heard.
Every SME does the same thing.
They say, well, they're
very well known.
And it is true within
their own circle.
So if it's within a
public relations circle,
or within an IT circle, they
probably are very well known,
but they're not very well
known to a wider world.
So if you're sponsoring
within the community
because you just want the
community to know who you are,
what you do, you're
on their doorstep,
and they should really
be thinking of you
in terms of maybe
future employment,
and just saying to
people they're good guys,
and they're out there,
they're doing great work.
Then it will work
very well for that.
But you need research in
advance and research afterwards.
It doesn't have to
be hugely scientific.
You can-- so long as you
structure the questions.
You probably know
this, but so long
as you structure the questions
so that they're open enough
and people don't know
what the answer is.
Because if you ask people, do
you think Google is wonderful,
they say, yes, I do.
They think Google is
awful, they'd say probably.
If you say, what do
you think of Google,
you'll get an honest answer
because you haven't told them
what you expect.
You can do it by, if
it's a community thing,
you can send people out
into the community saying,
have you ever heard
of this organization?
Any idea of what they do?
Who's in the building
down on the corner there?
And you find out a
lot, but what you
do is you go back and do
same research afterwards.
And don't expect that
everybody will suddenly say,
oh my god, we've
all heard about you.
But if you get like a 5%
increase, that's good.
You're moving in
the right direction.
And again, it's targeted
to your audience.
So the people you stop to ask
questions of, we sent a group--
I'm sorry, it's very
long-winded answer.
But we sent a group
out at one stage.
And we were training
journalists.
And I sent them out to do
interviews with people.
And I said, now, be sure you
don't get all the same people.
So don't stop people
who look like you.
Stop people across
a mix of age groups.
Stop men and women.
Do everything from like
17 to 77, or something.
And try and make something,
make some kind of note
about middle-aged, senior
person, younger person,
so when you come
back, you can say,
I interviewed-- because
it was for radio.
So I interviewed 10 people.
Four of them would've under 25,
and the others were over 55.
And the guys actually were
Ital-- they were Italian.
Any Italians in the room?
They have a whole 'nother
way of doing things.
So then he went up and he
said, hello, I'm John Marco.
So please, you'll tell
me how old are you?
And they said,
I'm 36 and a half.
I'm 42.
I couldn't believe it.
If an Orange person did
it, they would pick me up
off the ground.
But it's the audience
you're trying to reach.
So if you target the age
group as well carefully,
but that also means watching
who you send out to do it.
Send out a young person
to target older people,
they won't do it as well.
Send out an older person that's
in same age group stopping him,
you'll get more honest answers.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
before you wrote your book,
did you know what audience
you were targeting,
or did that come along
when you were writing?
How did you decide your
audience, or do you target?
ELLEN GUNNING: What
happened was this
is my second book
about public relations.
The first book that I wrote
is called "Public Relations--
A Practical Approach."
And it's studied by everybody
in Orange who studies PR.
So, we're expecting
more colleges
to-- it's an academic text.
It's an [INAUDIBLE].
It's a doorstop.
It's about 600
pages or something.
I actually thought that
I'd be revising that book
but not doing
anything else with PR.
And I had met with Mercier
Press, who published the book.
And I actually met with
them about a client's book.
And they had said--I
sent them the page.
And they came back
and said, actually, we
wouldn't be interested.
We'll meet you, and we would
be interested in publishing
the book for the client.
So I said, that's fine.
I really appreciate you
having a look at it.
Where else should
we go with the book?
Who else should publish it?
And at the end of
the conversation,
she says, you're
never going to write
another book on public
relations yourself, did you?
And I said, well, to
answer your question, no,
because I've kind
of covered everybody
who studies the subject.
And she said, well,
why what about SMEs?
Oh, yeah.
I [INAUDIBLE].
I have no sense.
They say yes to all the
things that interest me.
And then give out
[INAUDIBLE] and just
say, why did I decide to
d-- who scheduled this?
Me.
But I actually
thought, great idea.
And it was completely
different because essentially
what I'll do is-- and I know
the things that SMEs use,
but it gave me an opportunity
to go out and look
for companies in that sector.
Because we all look at
the larger companies,
so let's look at
smaller companies
and see how they're
using it well,
and how we could use
them as case studies.
So the audience
almost found itself
because that was that the
press came for the book.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thank you.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
I have someone here.
ELLEN GUNNING: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, I was
thinking about the sponsorship
and the fact that it's very
good for the brand awareness,
that it's needed in a very
initial phase of the business.
What happens when you do
something bad with this PR
tool?
So you basically
compromise your reputation
in a very initial phase.
So, do you have an example of--
good example of
how some business
could have recovered from
a bad usage of sponsorship?
ELLEN GUNNING: It's
a very interesting
[INAUDIBLE] on reputation.
Reputation takes a
lifetime to build,
and about 30 seconds to lose.
Was it Warren Buffett
who said, if you
think that everything you
do will be publicly known,
you'll be very careful
about what you do.
And that's about reputation,
because you lose reputation
very easily.
People do very stupid
things with reputation.
Probably one of the
best examples was the--
I can't get the
name of the company.
Was it [? Tremmell? ?]
The company
who had-- do you remember
when there was-- going back
25 years or more, the company
where that guy was actually
injecting Tylenol into
tablets in the States?
And it was Tylenol tablets.
I just remembered
the brand name.
They used injecting cyanide
into Tylenol tablets.
Anyway, it made people
very nervous about actually
using the product.
And they had a great reputation.
They were very well known.
And what they did was--
and most people in New York
thought they were
crazy at the time.
What they did was they
withdrew all of the products
from the shelves.
And they put messages
up everywhere saying,
do not use our product.
If you have it at
home, bring it back.
We'll give you a full refund.
For God's sake, don't
take any tablets.
We don't know what's going on.
We don't want anybody to
die because they've taken--
I think two people
in New York had died.
And we don't know
what's happened.
Everybody said, you
know, great move.
From PR point of view, obviously
they care about the customers.
They're going to have
nothing left to come back to,
because they've left this
gap, and their competitors
were taking over.
And when they came back, they
came back with that foil seal.
And they said, so now
we've made it extra safe.
So now you will
know if anybody has
tampered with these tablets.
You'd check.
Seals shouldn't be broken.
The foil should be intact.
It was very clever, and
they recovered market share
very quickly because
people actually said,
they care about us.
An example of one
who got it very wrong
was Shell in the States, when
they did all that damage.
And they sent over-- and
where they got it wrong
was from minute one.
They sent over an English
chief executive, an English PR
person--
or UK PR person,
and a UK lawyer.
So you had-- you're in the
States, (AMERICAN ACCENT)
where talks like this, OK?
So like, what to they do?
OK, they're after messing
the whole thing up,
and you get, (BRITISH ACCENT)
hello, I'm a chief executive.
And I'm over here, an American.
I'm going to sort it out.
Hello, I'm the PR person.
I'm over here with him.
Just common sense says respect
the country that you're in.
Now, that's down to reputation.
If you actually respect your
customers, like once you get
somebody with local eyes
and ears on the ground,
you get somebody who's American
who says this is how it works.
This is how-- just language.
This is how people will
interpret what you're saying.
And their reputation
suffered massively.
I'm not sure that
it's recovered yet.
But you'll find enough
of that company,
when their reputation's
severely damaged,
they actually completely
rename the company,
because they didn't--
the research says you
won't recover, as people will
always associate you with
the disaster.
So they have no option.
But it's a good example
of if you don't get right,
how much damage you can do.
That's the other side.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's fantastic.
Thank you so much.
I love that.
That was amazing.
Fantastic stories.
And I know there are
a few more questions
that we don't have
time to get around to,
but you have different ways
that we can contact you
that you've already
shared with me,
so I can share them
out with everyone else.
So, thank you again for being
our first speaker of the year.
ELLEN GUNNING: No problem,
thank you as well.
[APPLAUSE]
And you did say everybody
chases out at 12 noon.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]